good morning John it's Friday for the
last couple of weeks I've been thinking
a lot about boundaries the boundary
between public and private the borders
between nations the thresholds of our
lives and the fault lines of ideology
interviewing President Obama was
something that I could never regret but
being thrown into the public eye has
resulted in some people saying nasty
things about me which I'm not actually
that used to so I've been trying to look
at it all from outside of my own
experience my graduate degree is in
environmental science
so I often see my experiences through
the lens of ecology boundaries are
exceptional places ecologically the area
where two biomes blend is called an
ecotone and they tend to be more diverse
and biologically productive than either
biome alone many species specialize in
survival on that edge where access to
both biomes increases the available
resources the edge in other words is a
fantastic place but it's also a violent
place predators have access to more pray
and pray have to watch out for more
predators that tension is in nature what
drives increases in productivity and
diversity the edge between land and sea
has always been and remains a source of
great biological productivity but it's
also given rise to great cultural and
economic productivity as well the edge
effect it seems exists outside of
ecology there are personal edges whether
it's the finite moment of a person
becoming a parent or a more drawn-out
transition like that of a child becoming
an adult difficult times
yes but full of deeply valuable personal
growth and just as ecological boundaries
are massively productive and tumultuous
and wonderful
so our boundaries between cultures and
in the last week I've tried to see the
political debate in this country that
way I've tried to imagine that the
boundary between ideologies is a
tumultuous yet productive place and
occasionally it is but the benefits from
a boundary come not from a harsh edge
where the ocean meets a wall the
ecosystem does not become more
productive the most productive ecoute
owns are those that stretch out over
miles the ocean eating the land and the
land eating the ocean in a never-ending
burr
that gives rise to beautiful but
impenetrable wetlands instead of reaping
the benefits of a gradient between
ideologies I see people intentionally
poisoning it in order to protect their
perceived righteousness eventually you
have what ecologists call a monoculture
one plant as far as the eye can see
a desert of diversity that may be
productive but is extremely unstable any
outside influence can crash the entire
system I do not want to live in a world
of ideological monocultures and I do not
think that I do but pretending like we
do is in the best interests of a few
people who happen to have a lot of power
so I do not propose dismantling the
boundary I propose celebrating it
ideological diversity is not a sign of a
divided nation it's a sign of a
thoughtful nation and I found that the
best way to really believe this is to
simply stop listening to the people
telling us to hate each other as wrong
as you might think other people are you
are never going to always be right
everyone will be stronger if viewpoints
are allowed to mix into a diversity of
ideas and strategies the ecological
success of the edge comes from this
mixing and I think it's an important
part of the success of democracy as well
yes one side is going to feel safer to
you it's going to make more sense to you
but to reach our full potential we need
to merge that divide into a biome all
its own more fertile more diverse and
more productive than we could ever be
alone John I'll see you on Tuesday